- Ils n'ont pas eu autant
d'activité qu'ils avaient
espéré, quoi.
- Il y a quelquemomois,
cette propriété se serait vendue
en un clin d'oeil. Une maison
unifamiliale dans l'ouest
de Toronto pour moins de
trois millions de dollars.
Les acheteurs s'y seraient
bousculés. Mais aujourd'hui,
la situation est différente.
THTHOMAS DELESPIERRE,
agent immobilier, Toronto
- Ce n'était pas rare de voir
40 visites pour un week-end,
Là, si on a dix visites, c'est
un peu plus la norme, quoi.
- Une baisse d'activités que
cet agent immobilier attribue
à la hausse des taux d'intérêt.
- La capacité d'emprunt
des ménages, à cause de
l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt, a baissé
d'environ 25 %.
ROBERT HOGUE, économiste
Banque Royale du Canada
- On passe d'un marché qui était
absolument en surchauffe
à un marc q qui commence
à perdre des plumes.
- Un réajustement nécessaire,
croit cet économiste.
- On commence à voir aussi les
ixix qui commencent à reculer
quelque peu, là.
- Laurence vient d'acheter
une nouvelle maison. Elle fait
partie de ceux qui ont profité
de ce renversement de vapeur.
- Le prix est très bon.
- Un achat à rabais,
qui fait en sorte que l'avocate
ne s'inquiète pas trop de
la hausse des taux d'intérêt.
C'est le coût de la vie
en général qui la préoccupe.
- On peut trouver des façons
de compenser pour le 400 $,
le 1000 $ de plus qu'on paie
en hypothèque par mois
potentiellement parce qu'on se
dit : OK, si je tiens bien assez
longtemps finalement, je vais
revenir, ça va être corrrect.
Mais mgeger, il faut qu'on mange
trois fois par jour,
c'est ça qui est inquiétant.
(sonnette)
- Gemma aussi a achetéune nouven
pendant la pandémie.
- Celle-ci je l'ai trouvée,
elle n'était pas sur le marché.
- L'agente immobilière a cisisi
une hypothèque à taux variable.
GEMMA LEGGETT,
courtière et immobilière
- J'ai choisi d'avoir un taux
variable où mes remboursements
vont être les mêmes chaque
semaine, mais je verrai
la différence à la fin du terme.
- S' l lui faudra un peu plus
de temps pour rembourser
son prêt, Gemma croit quand même
avoir fait une bonne affaire.
- Si vous regardez aux années 80
par exemple, où on était
à plus de 10 %, plus de 12 %
de taux d'inrrêt, aujourd'hui,
on est encore vraiment, vraiment
très bas, donc il faut
vraiment relativiser.
- Et aux acheteurs,
Gemma lance ce message...
- Je pense vraiment que
c'est le moment d'acheter.
"C'esenencore inabordable",
rétorque Eric Lombardi, un
défenseur du droit au logement.
"Les prix ont beau descendre
dit-il, le marché reste
complètement inaccessible,
surtout pour les jeunes."
Car même avec un marché
qui refroidit, la réalité reste
la même : un manque de logements
et une population qui explose.
Pour beaucoup de Torontois,
l'accès àa a propriété reste
donc un rêve lointain, et ce,
peu importe le taux directeur.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto.